[Music]
[Applause]
you may remove your mask
[Music]
all right well don't necessarily keep
the applause going dr anthony found you
with us right now the white house chief
medical advisor wasn't keen on this
judge's decision joins us
right now dr fanchi very good to have
you back
thank you neil good to be with you i
caught your quote sir in which you said
that
this is a cdc issue it should not have
been a court
issue uh what did you mean by that
well exactly what what i said neil that
this this is a public health issue
and the point that i was making is that
you always respect
a decision of a judge in a court and in
fact that's what's happening right now
because masks
are coming off in transportation
planes and and other forms of
transportation
but the point that i was making that
this is a public health decision
and i think it's a bad precedent when
decisions
about public health issues are made by
by people be they judges or what have
you
that don't have experience or expertise
in public health and i believe that this
should mean should remain
a cdc decision and the cdc
has a very large number of experienced
scientists and epidemiologists that make
those
judgments based on
the dynamics of the outbreak on the
ground and other considerations that
they make so i wasn't at all
defying the authority of a judge because
when the judge makes a decision you
abide by that decision
i was concerned about the principle of
having non-public health
people making public health decisions so
what about the cdc weighing in on you
know
a rental eviction moratorium now the
supreme court
did take that up uh should the cdc have
not
you know that's an area neil that that
i'm really not that familiar with to be
honest with you i'm not trying to evade
your question but i have not been
involved in looking at the details of
that and i really would be a bit
hesitant to make any kind of
determination on that wouldn't a court
be a better place though to to deal on
an issue like you know a rental
moratorium
than a health entity though
you know neil i i really can't say on
that because it's a different situation
than what you asked me about regarding
the public health dangers or not
of being in a closed place in
transportation i would have to really go
back and take a look at that before i
make any statement about
about evictions
so on the masking in general doctor
people are very very confused uh
it it might be taken off on planes and
that's fine uh but depending on where
you land let's say in the new york
metropolitan area laguardia or jfk you
have to put the mass back on if you're
in new jersey at newark airport you
don't um
philadelphia had a massive requirement
then lifted a massive requirement la i
can't keep up with what's going on here
you could see why americans are confused
right
no i i agree with you neil there there
is a you know a reason for concern and
confusion because there are differences
of risk when you're on a close place
in an air first of all
i don't know what the ultimate decision
that the cdc
will make you recall that the expiration
of that requirement on transportation
for april 18th the cdc extended it
for 15 days to may third and the reason
they needed that
is that we are in a dynamic situation
where we're in a situation
where the cases had gone down
dramatically over the past several weeks
but now with the ba2 we're starting to
see a blip up in
cases and what the cdc is trying to
determine is that going to be
reflected in an increase in
hospitalizations which is the new metric
that they're using about making their
determinations about requirements for
masks
in indoor settings as well as in places
like transportation so it's kind of a
moving target
so they were asking
for another 15 days to get to may 3rd
then when the court overruled that and
said that masks were coming off it's
understandable
how there could be some confusion they
may have decided to pull back on the
mask anyway by may 3rd i don't know
they're using the science and what's
going on
on the ground but you're right i mean
when you have that kind of back and
forth of course that people might be
confused by that you know um you had
said uh and i think i'm quoting her
correctly doctor no chance we will be
able to eliminate the covet virus uh
you would also added that there's a new
cove environment uh that are constantly
coming soon you didn't say constantly i
apologize i i i'm wondering though when
when someone as esteemed as you says you
know this whole covet thing
it's it's not going away
that scares people
what do you think well
well neil it's the reality because take
a look at the history i don't think it
should necessarily scare people maybe
well i will and thank you for giving me
the opportunity to to explain it a bit
if you look at the history of infectious
diseases outbreaks namely typical
respiratory-borne illnesses we've only
completely eradicated from the planet
one virus that afflicts humans and
that's smallpox that's eradication
elimination means
where you haven't eradicated it from the
globe but you've essentially eliminated
it for example from a given country
take the united states
so what have we done we've done that
with measles and we've done that with
polio but there were three factors that
went into our ability to do that
one
measles and polio is not a virus that
changes the measles that we had 20 30
years ago is the same measles we have
right now number one number two
either infection induced
or vaccine-induced immunity is virtually
lifelong and as a matter of fact
that's what we had and then you had a
very very effective widely acceptable
and widely accepted vaccination campaign
that's why we were able to eliminate it
but if you look at saw's kobe 2 and
kovid
first of all we have a virus that has a
great degree of variability we know that
from the variants two
the immunity either from infection or
from vaccine wanes over time
and we don't have a wide acceptance
of vaccination
so i believe that we're not going to be
able to eliminate it it will hopefully
get down to a low enough level
where it does not disrupt society
doesn't disrupt the economy it doesn't
disrupt our social interests really it
could right because
but you also said
and i believe we can do that
particularly if we get more people
vaccinated to get it at a low enough
level where it doesn't disrupt us that's
what i was trying to say where i don't
think we're ever going to get rid of it
but i was asking you about this hurt
immunity thing of which you seem to have
your doubts that it might not apply to
covet if you're right
then um it is a constant it is back and
a reminder with us indefinitely uh this
happens at a time when we're getting
again disparate advice on how many shots
you get one dose two those three doses
how they're spaced apart
what do you recommend
you know i i don't think we can make a
firm recommendation now because again
neil it is a bit of a moving target the
one thing we do know
that everyone really does need a third
shot a boost if you have the two shots
of an mrna the the the data on that what
if the antibodies don't hold as long as
you thought and all of a sudden now
that's in question um and that that
applies to a lot of the vulnerable but
for example mike myself so i'm wondering
then how that changes what you recommend
obviously
different you know
pieces of advice for some patients
versus others but how do you
when people seek your medical advice on
this what do you tell them
well what i tell them is that everybody
whether you have an underlying condition
or not whatever your age
if you're eligible to get vaccinated for
that third boost get that third boost
for sure
the real question then is what about a
fourth dose
who needs a fourth dose and you know the
fda
and the cdc has gone along with this
have now made eligible for that fourth
dose
people who are 50 years old or older and
particularly people who are 65 and older
and definitely people who might have
underlying conditions that make them
more likely to get a severe outcome so
as a physician if i'm in an office or in
my clinic at the nih and someone comes
in who's 52 years old 53 years old and
might have hypertension or diabetes i
unequivocally would recommend that they
get that fourth dose without a doubt
so doctor um in china you know cases are
still spiking for i believe this ba sub
variant you referred to it's enough to
keep shanghai all but shut down some
people have been allowed out of their
homes but most not uh
and i'm just wondering their response to
the spike in cases there which indeed is
a spike but a fraction of what it was at
the height
just do do you fear some
get overreactive and that lockdowns like
that uh are overdoing it
well no doubt neil i mean that is i
believe counterproductive
if you are going to shut down you shut
down for the reason of giving you the
opportunity
to do things like vaccinating your
population
to protect them you cannot shut down
indefinitely for the virus the virus
will ultimately
infiltrate society
and what the chinese have done which i
think is not a good public health
practice
is that they have not fully vaccinated
their people and the vaccine that they
use is not a particularly effective
vaccines and they have a lot of
vulnerable people
particularly the elderly who have not
been vaccinated so to just shut down and
think you're going to escape the virus
without doing
the important things
to allow society to open up again
namely vaccinating people making
therapies available for the people who
get infected
that's the only reason to do a temporary
shutdown but to think that you're going
to shut down and keep the virus out
indefinitely
is really something that is just not
feasible so your thoughts then mayor
eric adams in new york it seems to be
hitting that the vaccine mandate for
city workers will remain in effect he is
not going to
take that back
what do you think of that
you know neil as i've always said
you leave those local decisions
to the local authorities i mean there
are broad general public health
principles that are applicable
universally
but things are different on the ground
at different locations and that's why i
and many of my colleagues
have always been in favor of creating
and and articulating broad public health
principles but leaving the ultimate
decision
to the locals because each locality be
it new york or texas or any other place
florida seattle and san francisco
they're all different
they have differences that i think need
to be taken into consideration
when the local authorities make those
decisions
um doctor finally if i could weigh in on
you know politics i know you would skew
this subject probably wisely uh but
steve moore former top advisor to him
was just on our show saying he had had
dinner with the former president a
couple of nights ago and he's fully
convinced that is steve moore that the
president is going to run again and he's
polling well against joe biden in fact
depending on the poll up by a couple of
points to as much as eight points
so if he were to become president again
would you
stay in your current capacity
uh
or want to
you know neil
my staying or not in my current capacity
has absolutely nothing to do
with who the president of the united
states is
i'm a scientist
i'm a public health official and i run
an institute that has a major role
in the development of countermeasures
and doing the science against
these types of emerging infections that
has never been
dependent on
who was in office in the presidency or
who controlled the congress it's fair to
say
doctor it was a bit of a fractious you
were the public face of this obviously
and as you have been in prior
administrations as well
uh
it would it would seem unlikely that you
would be in a new trump administration
or am i overstating
i think you're overstating because my
position is not a political
position and decisions that i make
about my job as a public health official
and a scientist
believe you have to believe me neil it
has nothing to do
with politics and who's in office and
who's not in office and any decisions
about what i do will be completely
independent of that i promise you so
just to be clear on this you've worked
with president biden you work with
president trump you weren't many
presidents but obviously prominently
these two
do you have a preference who you work
with who makes your job easier who makes
your job more helpful who's more
conducive to the kind of things that you
talk about
you know
again neil i think you said it in the
beginning of your question i stay out of
politics and you're asking me a
completely political question and i'm
not going to answer that
okay so you have president trump in a
boat and president biden i'm kidding i'm
kidding um dr anthony fauci very very
good seeing you
again thank you very very much
thank you neil it's always good to be
with you